hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast developing bioinformatics
approaches to understand the functional
consequences of gene expression
variability presented by dr. Jessica
Meier assistant professor at the Albert
Einstein College of Medicine in the
department of systems and computational
biology in the donkey work I am Marjorie
Torrez of lab use and I'll be your
moderator for today's list we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab lab words
of the leading scientific social
networking website and producers
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone this is event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button we'll hit it in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation is a
slide window to enlarge this window just
click on the screen icon located under
lower ray if you have trouble singing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Jessica mana I will now turn the
presentation over her
hi everybody well thank you so much
Marjorie for the kind introduction and
many thanks to elaborate for the
opportunity to present some of the
research that we've been doing in my lab
I'd like to echo Marjorie's a comment
about questions I'm more than happy to
take questions that you may have after
viewing this presentation so please feel
free to send them through I'm going to
go ahead and get started and talk about
the focus of the work in my lab which is
centered around the idea of gene
expression variability so as Marjorie
mentioned I am part of the systems
biology department at Albert Einstein
College of Medicine and one of the big
things that we do as systems biologists
is we really want to understand what
gene regulatory networks look like and
for the stems from the phenomenon where
we now live in a world that we note that
cells operate through the integrated
action of many different genes we
understand that one gene one phenotype
is no longer a paradigm that holds and
for assistance biologists what we spend
a lot of time thinking about is how to
model these networks accurately so for
instance what genes go into these
networks and also how does information
flow through these networks to control
and regulate different cell phenotypes
so when we think about how networks
operate we understand that certain genes
that are in these networks are
controlled by different levels of signal
but what we're coming to recognize more
recently is that noise plays a big
feature in regulating these networks too
and in the recent past studying will
worry with in in some of the papers in
2010 and 2011 there's been some
beautiful work that's been done in the
context of C elegans and I've listed one
example here in Rodge ed Hall who showed
that actually there was an increase in
gene expression variability that was
downstream of and
Jeanne and this variability that was
seen at the gene expression level was in
fact explanatory of the incomplete
penetrance associated with the mutation
in this particular gene burger at all in
2011 had another nature paper that
showed actually the link in synthetic
lethality and the expression variability
of one of the synthetic lethal
interaction partners and he showed that
also in C elegans that increases in gene
expression variabilities of the
synthetic lipid partner actually
determined again the incomplete
penetrance of the trait so we have these
examples that come to us from model
systems that demonstrate how important
the variability of gene expression is in
the context of these regulatory networks
and so when we think more generically
about the signal transduction pathways
that we know are relevant for every
single cell there is a importance of
understanding how signal and noise
contribute to the proper regulation of
these networks and so you can think
about a generic signal transduction
pathway that's made up of different
molecules that have different roles so
for instance receptors kinases or
transcription factors and if we think
about surveying or capturing the
transcriptional snapshot of this pathway
from cell to cell or from patient to
patient we can imagine following the
level of variability or consistency in
these gene expression values so you can
imagine that the distribution of
expression variability is is not equal
throughout this pathway and paying
attention to those extremes or degrees
of variability can actually tell us
about transcriptional stability or the
degree of regulatory constraint so if
you think about this a little bit
further the idea that some genes may
have low variance is indicative than of
tighter regulatory constraints or
control in the system and on the other
side we can think about high variability
or high variance reflecting greater
header region a which may state
increase functional plasticity or a
greater diversity of cell fates that
might be the outcome of those particular
genes so I'd like to emphasize that
variability is really an inevitable
component of any biological system and
as our tools and technology improves
we're really being reminded is the fact
with more and more data that we collect
but only think about why this is the
case why this is such an inherent
feature it's pretty clear from the gene
expression perspective and that's
because we know that gene expression is
the product of a series of biochemical
reactions so as we know for a transcript
to be made there needs to be a whole set
of different molecules that have to come
together physically in order for this
process to move forward and some of
these components like transcription
factors or cofactors can either be
spatially regulated and also present at
low concentrations so that the actual
event of producing a transcript is a
probabilistic event for housekeeping
genes that probability may occur with
0.9999 9% or nine high certainty but
there's still that small element of
stochasticity there and that's what
posit I'd really like to emphasize here
that when we look at the distribution
across the transcriptome there is
stochastic sitting there in the gene
expression of certain genes and what
we're coming to understand is that some
genes have variability that seems to be
buffered or compensated for by other
processes and have no effect on the
phenotype and in other circumstances
there is variability in some genes that
can lead to quite distinct phenotypic
outcomes so one of the focus points of
my lab is really to understand what is
what is it about certain genes that seem
to be buffered and others that have
variability that's really quite key in
the phenotypic consequences of of that
distribution so another way to think
about gene expression
dottie is in the context of looking at
distinguishing factors when we're trying
to understand regulation of a particular
phenotype and in gene expression what we
often do is we use a statistic like a t
statistic to understand the genes that
are differentially expressed between one
initech or another so you may recall
that the T statistic is just a ratio of
the average expression difference
between two groups that's divided by the
amount of noise or variability in the
two systems and we can see this
graphically so for instance if we're
comparing a diseased group and a control
group then the genes that we are going
to pick up as differentially expressed
of those that have the biggest
difference in average divided by the
most consistent expressions or those
genes in a very consistent will have a
smaller degree of noise and therefore
the overall T statistic that we find
will be much larger and therefore more
likely to be significant and this is a
very sensible way of identifying genes
that are important to one phenotype or
another but one of the limitations is it
misses out on changes in gene expression
variability and I've got two cartoons
here to illustrate what I mean by that
so for instance there's one example
where for instance the variability of
the gene in the disease group may be
much more heterogeneous whereas in the
control group the stability is that gene
is quite tight or quite quite small and
the more extreme example on the right
side is where on average this gene is
expressed equally in the control and the
disease group but you can see that that
the variability is is quite different so
in disease disease groups expression of
this gene is much more heterogeneous
that may be due to an upstream mutation
or snips in the promoter region or some
other regulatory factor or so too
and if we were only focusing on the
t-statistic we would miss this detail so
I think there is a a reason to work out
both changes in variability as well as
Cage's is an expression truly understand
the underlying regulators of a specific
phenotype and so some of the earlier
work that I've been involved in has been
looking at this specific question in the
context first of human stem cells that
we collected from neurological diseases
for instance Parkinson's disease and
schizophrenia and so using a stem cell
model that was collected from a factory
cells and turned into neural cells
through these factory
neurosurg arrives so what we did was we
were able to look at patient variability
in these stem cell models of these
disorders which as you can appreciate
her are very difficult just to study in
living patients and so the study we did
was published a while ago in 2011 and
PLoS genetics and basically what we did
was we looked at changes in gene
expression variability between this
different patient groups as well as a
group of related controls and when we
looked at specific pathways that were
relevant to these stem cell populations
we noticed that there were differences
in gene expression variability is such
that there were increases in the
Parkinson's disease group and decreases
in the schizophrenia group and for the
controls that were somewhere in the
middle so there was really suggested
that variability at either extreme was
present in a disease state and we looked
further at the functional roles
associated with these changes is
variability we noticed interesting
things in terms of differences in cell
surface receptors as well as
transcription factors and also the
connectivity of these genes in terms of
the different protein protein
interactions they operated in so more
recently what my lab has been thinking
about is how we can use variability but
also some other related statistics to
really understand
the regulatory distribution of genes in
a particular population and so what I
want to do is is take you back to have
high school statistics where we often
look at the probability density of a
specific data set and so in this example
what I have is a density that's been
drawn for a single gene that's been
captured in a single cell population so
each point along this density represents
the gene expression level in a single
cell and we have a population as well
appear so statistics tells us different
aspects about this particular
distribution and you're all familiar
with I'm sure the first moment which is
the median or the mean it measures the
center of this distribution and when we
think about these moments these are
underlying outside these are statistics
that report on different aspects of the
population in the data so our first
moment is the median of mean the second
moment is the variance which measures
spread of this distribution but if we
keep going there are actually higher
moments above the second moment that we
don't often always talk about and for
the third moment is skewness which is
something you may have already heard of
and as we keep going we have hyper
skewness hypo flatness and as we move
further the interpretability of these
moments tends to get a bit vague but
what is really interesting is that there
are biological features that we can
extract from these high-end moments and
extend them to to look at other features
such as by modality or multi-modality
which is certainly a feature that's
relevant to single cell data so what I
had to do is talk to you about some of
the ways that we're using these moments
to infer more about the underlying
biology and I think this was really
relevant and important because in bio
cymatics often our methods really only
focus in that first moment and there
really is a lot of biology to be
explored if we go higher
so what I want to do today in this
presentation is talk about three
separate projects that we have in the
lab one of them starts off with dealing
with the method that we've developed to
understand gene expression variability
in the context of pathways
I want to then talk about cancer biology
in two areas where one we've been
looking at changes in gene expression
variability to look at genes that are
much more tightly regulated in the tumor
versus normal and finally some examples
of how easy skewness and gene expression
as a way to understand regulation of
tumors in a different way so without
further ado I'd like to start off by
introducing path gar and this is a tool
that we've developed in my lab it was
recently accepted for publication in PHA
and it's been available in bioconductor
as a standalone package for over a year
now
and this is what that has been done by
my postdoc walls to tante and my program
is an Zimmerman and our early sentence
on this very basic idea of thinking
about the distribution of gene
expression from patient to patient or
for looking at single cells from cell to
cell and understanding what is that
distribution of variability across the
pathway that we have in our database or
the gene set that we've collected from a
particular study and we can actually use
that information in the form of the
distribution of variability that we see
in tunnel B where some Jensen was
possibly are expressed with much lower
variability versus other genes that are
much more variable and we want to use
this distribution to understand which
genes belong to either of these extremes
to understand how transcriptional
stability or regulatory constraint is
distributed within this particular
pathway so the PI star method can
function in a one group setting or a
tier group setting and I'll give you
some examples of what I mean by that but
essentially the outline of this method
is quite straightforward step one stops
with a diagnostic plot that helps the
user
determine which statistic to use to
measure variability the second step is
to then use the statistic to analyze
through each pathway the levels of gene
expression variability that we see and
assess whether this distribution of low
medium high variable genes is different
or aberrant either from the reference if
we're working in a one group setting or
between the two phenotypes that were
contrasting and then there's a few
different visualization steps to
facilitate proper interpretation so in
terms of measuring variability this is
something that there are several
different statistical estimators that
can be used for this purpose and as with
all statistics there are pros and cons
with using one versus another in terms
of looking at expression data what we
found is that a good way to decide in
which which statistic to use can be
determined by looking at the correlation
or the distribution between the
variability statistic and average
expression and the rationale behind that
is that what we see sometimes is that
there is correlation between these two
statistics and what we want to do is
select a variability statistic where
there's less correlation or least
correlation because that way we can
investigate changes and variability that
aren't purely recapitulating the changes
that we see in average expression so we
did some work into looking out which of
these estimators performs better than
the other this is what that's available
in a posture next paper that we had in
2015 we did very simulation studies and
we found that the standard deviation
often is a more reliable less correlated
estimator
but I want to highlight that this is not
something that happens in every single
dataset and in fact it it seems to be
data specific and this is something that
we're still working on and her
to add more clarity to that this was
really a reason for investigating how
you're estimated behaves in your data
because it can vary depending on the
data that you're looking at so if we go
back to what pop R is doing if we take
this example of comparing the
distribution of water medium high
variability genes in a pathway versus a
reference like this this does two
comparisons that are occurring here that
we care about so the first comparison is
this here where basically what we're
trying to do is test the null hypothesis
that the reference in population is same
variability count distribution okay so
basically does the histogram on the
right look the same as the histogram on
the left and the way we assess up
statistically is through the use of a
chi-squared test which has asymptotic
assumptions which means it becomes more
accurate as a sample sizes increase or
we can also use a multinomial statistic
which is really nice because it's an
exact statistic so it computes the
people are you exactly the second kind
of comparison we're also then interested
in testing is between the same level of
variability so for instance oops this
one here but the lower variability
counts we want to compare whether this
number in the reference is the same as
the number here in the pathway one that
we're testing so this is only looking at
low to lower between the two groups and
this is done through a binomial mistake
we're now assessing whether this
specific pathway has a different number
of lower variability genes than we'd
expect compared to the reference so what
I wanted to do next then is show you an
example of what I mean and here what
we've done is we've used data from the
block paper which acade and saw in 2011
which was Michener a data but purse of
two populations of cells there were
human es es embryonic stem cells and
they wanted to compare the gene
expression profiles it says with
Jews clear potent stem cells so it's
taters a little bit old but we think
it's relevant just to highlight
differences that we're seeing here and
so those three pathways that were
significant among some others that were
quite interesting that we wanted to
highlight here were KEGG pathways so
these were the spliceosome oxidative
phosphorylation and ECM receptor
interactions and you can see that the
shapes of variability distribution are
quite different from the reference and
in this case the reference is all the
genes that were profiled on the
microarray with some initial filtering
steps of quality so what we've done with
this pathway is oh sorry see what we've
done with this package and this method
is if extent that we tested it
extensively in different kinds of data
platforms in addition to my Quraish
we've also tested this with RNA seek
data we've tested this on single cell
datasets as well as bulk human mouse
house parasites other stem cell
populations and that's all part of the
paper that you can find in in PHA so in
the to group comparison instead of
comparing es es to the reference we can
also compare ESS directly to the changes
that we're seeing in induced pluripotent
stem cells and so this is another
feature that maybe is more relevant to
the question that you're interested in
exploring with your datasets and the
same kind of principles apply so here
what we've done is highlighted two cake
pathways that were differentially
variable between the two stem cell
populations our oxidative
phosphorylation and DNA replication and
you can see that there's quite different
structures here so for ops for instance
we see a much higher representation of
lower variability genes in the esc
population and for instance in the DNA
replication slide a subset of those
genes seem to be much more variable
expressed in the IPS a population as you
can see
this baahir compared to the height of
the spa here so you can see that the
interpretation is is quite
straightforward and then through the
software what you can do is you can then
pull out the genes that are present for
these particular highly variable genes
and understand which parts of the DNA
replication pathway or genes that are
much more variable H R estimate SPSS the
essays so this package as I mentioned is
available on bioconductor please feel
free to check it out and if you have any
questions or concerns please let me know
and we'd be happy to understand how we
can make the cell phone more relevant so
what I wanted to mention to you was also
the extensive testing that we've done
but also in the context of other methods
obviously in bioinformatics there's lots
of different methods out there for
understanding how pathways contribute to
changes in transcriptional regulation
and so what we wanted to highlight was
how possible was either different or the
laughing with other methods that we
commonly use and so what we've done is
we've used GSC alm which is an r package
from the gentleman lab that was used to
look at a gene set enrichment through a
linear model we've also used gene set
enrichment in a different context where
we're contrasting the distribution of P
values in this case of using limo to
assess differences between the two
groups and so here in this more
traditional version of GSE a we're
looking at changes in the p value
distributions and so here I've only got
the counts of the pathways if you're
interested in understanding what those
pathways are I can definitely share
those with you but essentially what we
see is that there are some pathways that
are uniquely picked up by pasta or a
method and others that are uniquely
picked up by the GOC a approaches and
then there's ones that are so in common
we also looked at using pasta where
instead of based
the variability we also basis around
average expression and so this was a way
to highlight how a method structurally
might compare if we were looking instead
of variability we were looking at
differences in low medium and high
average levels of expression and so
there we see overlap considerable
overlap depending on the comparison that
we looked at and just to highlight in a
bit more detail we looked at a few
different comparisons three from
different Cancer Genome Atlas datasets
the BOK data that we used as well as a
stem cell dataset looking at down
syndrome versus wild-type or control
cells we also looked at a non human data
set from a neurological study done in
life so what I'm going to do now is just
switch gears and hopefully stay within
the time frame but I wanted to talk
about another study that one of my
students Cassandra Litchfield did more
recently what she was really interested
in looking at the distribution of gene
expression variability across different
tumor types and so the kind of question
that she wanted to answer was whether we
could find new regulators based on
changes and variability and specifically
did these regulators were these
different genes or the same across
different tumor types and the kind of
rationale or motivation for the study
started with a paper that we found from
2008 in PLoS genetics where they looked
at decreases in gene expression
variability in tumor versus matched
control samples and this was a very
illuminating study they found that genes
that had much tighter expression in the
tumor versus much control had quite a
functional effect on the viability of
the tumor and so the study was done a
little while ago
and it was done in the context of
microarrays and what we have the
opportunity to do now is is to really
look at a modern version of the study in
the context of the Cancer Genome Atlas
data but also with RNs
data that has many many more samples in
this original study so what Cassie did
was she took 12 different tumor types
and these all had matched control
samples and you can save their
representation of different sample sizes
that are in the table there and what she
did was she used the CV which is trying
to standard deviation divided by the
mean to identify a subset of genes that
were tightly regulated in cancer and
mathematically how she found loads was
to define those genes that fell in the
bottom 50 percentile of the CV in the
tumor and above the 15th percentile in
the CV of the normal samples so
basically these these genes correspond
to the yellow dots that are being shown
by that blue arrow and now also the to a
territory because what they they're
falling then in the lower lower set of
this this sorry I'm just confused by the
arrows here okay by the distribution
here and the phase a and much higher in
the normal sorry
but whatever reason these genes have a
much tighter expression distribution in
the tumor samples and so she identified
this subset of genes in each of the
tumor types that she was looking at and
then she wanted to answer the question
or investigate the question of whether
those overlap will similar groupings in
the tightly regulated genes that she'd
identified from tier medicina and so
what she did was she did a hierarchical
clustering here she'd cluster based on
the overlap and we saw some interesting
things where some tumor types clustered
together so for instance you can see
that the lung cancers clustered together
here also a thyroid and prostate cancers
also cluster together we think this is
because of the hormonal aspect of these
two tumors share you'll notice that
these kidney cancers also cluster
together but in fact
this kidney cancer does not and we think
that that could be due to a difference
in aggressiveness of these these tumors
but there are more more things we need
to look into for this study so what is
also interesting is that the structure
of this gender gram recapitulates what
was also observed in the context of
average gene expression and this was a
study that was done more recently by
paying at all in 2015 and there's a
really fantastic paper there in
scientific reports that looks at these
these different tumors as well but from
the context is average expression and
differential expression so what we
wanted to do then is given that though
it gives him two the overlap was look
for a common subset of genes that were
tightly regulated to a core of these
tumor types and so when you look at how
many genes are retained when you
increase the overlap we saw that were
nine out of twelve of the tumors that we
were considering
there are nine genes that are common to
old-line tumor types and this was
starting from an original set as about
18,000 genes so these are the nine genes
that are tightly regulated in all nine
of the 12 tumor types you may recognize
some of the genes that are in there and
what was quite interesting we thought
was that when you keep increasing that
threshold from nine up to all the way at
12 you do actually when you consider 10
cats would see a subset of these genes
that's still in common and what's
interesting about some of these students
is that they're known to have parallels
in cancer so these genes are selected
purely based on their height regulations
or purely data-driven selection and so
it's somewhat interesting that they have
rules that we already know
in terms of their influence on on tumor
regulation so another thing that Kathy
did was to apply pass by to investigate
the changes that we saw in different
pathways with respect to expression
variability by comparing the match
controls to the Tumen and so what she
saw was really quite interesting and
that a subset of pathways were
significant that were quite relevant to
cancer biology and she used cake
pathways in this instance and used
significance is defined by less than
0.01 p-values that were adjusted for
multiple testing and so we've used this
example from p53 signaling pathway as
you probably know this is a very
important and relevant pathway to cancer
biology and you can see based on the
distributions that the match controls
actually have many more tightly
regulated low variability genes than the
chima here and so when we look at the
other pathways that Kathy found these
were things like DNA replication
ubiquitin mediated paralysis and
mismatch repair we actually see the same
trend where as a loss or an increase in
heterogeneity in the pathway so we see
for instance the much more tightly
regulated genes here that drops off in
the tumor so we think this speaks to the
general instability or destabilization
of key pathways that occur in the tumor
which obviously we know about through
other studies or through other research
and I think the next steps here are
really to understand how this
possibility is contributing obviously as
part of the pathway that are being
disabled eyes but there's also
potentially passes the tumor that are
being more highly regulated which is
some of the earlier stuff that I
presented so putting both of these
pieces together gives us more
comprehensive on this
how transcriptional regulation is being
perturbed also in the context of these
two modes so finally what I wanted to
talk about was stepping away from
expression variability but moving on to
the next moment which you might recall
is the skewness statistic that we talked
about so this was a project that was
pioneered by one of the students in my
lab and Cech and with more recent
assistance from Henry Williams and both
Ben and Henry were really fascinated by
this idea of how skewness could be used
as a way to both model and then
understand gene expression had
originated and so we don't really tend
to talk about skewness in a quantitative
setting but qualitatively we understand
this to be instances where distributions
show a lot of asymmetry so this
asymmetry can be positive or negative by
both of these densities that we've got
and in terms of quantifying the skewness
then derived a statistic that takes into
account both the skewness the third
moment that we can calculate from a
distribution but this is standardized by
the standard deviation of the second
moment and I just wanted to point out
that tradish by a theoretical estimation
this is a biased estimator but the
actual degree applies especially for the
size of the data sets that were working
this is really quite minimal so this
isn't a huge concern but just it gives a
bit more background about why instead of
just taking the third moment we've
normalized statistics by the standard
deviation as a way to really highlight
the asymmetry that we're seeing in the
data and so just using the skewness
statistic we're not necessarily able to
distinguish distributions like in the
right hand panel that clearly is showing
deviations that we would like to model
in the gene expression distribution
so what Ben and Henry did was they
developed a pipeline to investigate
skewness using different data sets
including the Cancer Genome Atlas so
what they did was they applied the
skewness distribution to different gene
expression data sets in a normal and a
cancer setting they also developed a
statistic to determine the stability of
the convergence of this particular
skinners estimator so that we could
accept or reject data sets that were
insufficiently
large so we accepted those data sets
that showed reasonable convergence so we
were fairly sure that the accuracy at
least as this data was or the accuracy
of the skin of statistic was acceptable
and so what he did was then he looked at
genes that changed dramatically their
skewness in the cancer nose is normal so
maybe the gene was extremely skewed in
the cancer group but in a normal in the
normal data it was symmetric and when we
look at what those genes represent
they're largely represent different
metabolic or translational pathways in
the rna-seq the mercury data and then
and Henry found some slight differences
in the microwave of scientific data but
in terms of understanding we we are
interested more I think in the earnest
big data that we're seeing so another
thing that they did was then to try and
tie the scoot expression that they saw
with changes at the level of DNA
methylation so one of the nice things
about cancer genome atlas data is that
we have access to other data types that
had been perfect on the same patient so
what they did was they looked at genes
that were significant for changes in
methylation and also looked at how
skewed they were in these cattle
populations so they tried two different
approaches to determine which was the
most significant subset basically the
the two approaches were fairly similar
and from this day basically ranked the
top the the set that were most queued
the differentially methylated would say
and they took the top 500 and from that
what they wanted to do was look at the
relationship between DNA methylation and
the skewed genes in terms of expression
and so what you see here are different
relationships here for the kidney renal
cell carcinoma / heart and these are all
the different points for colored based
on the quadrants they fall into as you
may or may not know the way we interpret
gene with DNA methylation really depends
on where those words are falling so the
context really matters or is helpful to
know so we divided the faroe up into
where these were sales were annotated to
for instance promoter regions gene body
regions and the utr so what they found
was that there is a very negative
relationship or association between
genes based on their skewness and also
the change in end value in other words
the change in DNA methylation and they
used confidence intervals to assess the
significance of the Pearson correlation
coefficients and you can see that for
each of the 3 different genomic regions
that we looked at there's a quite a
significant negative correlation there
so this is quite interesting what they
wanted to do then was to determine given
that this is based off the top 500 genes
whether that subset selection had any
influence on the negative correlation
that we're seeing between skewness and
DNA methylation so what Ben and Henry
did was they they down sampled going
from 500 all the way down to 100 of the
significant jism they did this multiple
times to ensure that they had a
generalizable result or a stable result
and you can see in this graph that they
did this for the three different regions
that were interested in
the utr the promoter and missing bodies
region and you can see that basically
the negative correlation as you go from
the top 500 to the top 100 genes I
should get stronger so it gets more
negative which is reassuring because it
demonstrates this correlation the thing
is is robust to the size of the
significant genes that are being
considered okay out of all the different
three different locks we see that the
promote approach the loci that were
located in the promoter regions have the
greatest robustness compared to the
other regions and it also has the most
negative correlation and this suggests
the link between the skinners and the
DNA methylation reserving and this makes
a lot of sense given what we learned in
or about methylation of these loci in
the promoter regions and its
relationship to gene expression the
negative correlation we're seeing in the
gene body is also quite interesting and
we are still investigating that further
to really understand what that means so
what I'd like to do then is end the
presentation by acknowledging the people
in my lab and a lot of collaborators
that were virtually hot on these
different studies the pathway work was
done primarily by Laurel Souter on Tay
and also by Sam Zimmermann the cancer
tightly regulated study was done by
Kathy Litchfield who worked with me over
the summer base to the University of
Melbourne and finally in looking at
skewness which was done by
Ranieri work by Ben touch and Henry
Williams and we are really fortunate to
work with a whole host of different
collaborators both at Einstein and
located elsewhere and I'd like to thank
you for tuning in to my presentation
thank you
Thank You dr. Marc for that informative
presentation we will now start the last
human aid portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green
humanoid button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions will be a tag
below let's get started
our first question is what are some
possible interpretations to decrease or
increase changes in gene expression of
variability how can we use the other
sources resources to further further
investigate the underlying mechanisms or
functions that drives variability in
gene expression so that's a really
interesting question it's very broad and
I think there's many different ways to
answer that but I think in thinking
about increases or decreases and
variability of expressions could be for
instance due to in the case of increased
variability could be due to mixed cell
populations so for instance these cells
may just have very different transcript
terms because they have different cell
fates
or different cell types in the case of
increased or decreased by a gene
expression variability this could be an
indication of tighter regulatory control
so for instance housekeeping genes or
critical transcription factors or
critical social interceptive so I think
there's a very functional interpretation
to what these changes in gene expression
variability can lead us to the ways of
using further resources to understand
what those functions could be or what
the mechanistic interpretation of
variability could be there are lots of
ways that we can approach that in
somatically we could use
other annotation resources so for
instance like the gene ontology that has
different ontology like molecular
function also Euler component of
biological process we could look at
molecular function to try to understand
if certain cell surface receptors are
more variable or less variable those
basis sorts of things that we could
integrate in the context of this sort of
analysis what are some of the possible
limitations to using interface
variability as need to identify tightly
regulated genes are there other kinds of
experimental data that could be
supplement for augmenting interference
yes so one of the really great things
about working with patient cohort ATAR
is that we have we have a means to
really understand what are the disease
profiles like in terms of modeling those
changes but one other limitations is
that patients can have different
transcript terms with different changes
due to a variety of other factors and
they may not necessarily be relevant to
the disease or genetics of the disease
that we're really trying to get up so
there are issues with modeling inter
patient variability because these
patients might be on different drug
regimes they may have differences you
know in terms of life there may be
gender specific differences that are
influencing the changes that were seeing
they may be in different environments
all sorts of factors that we haven't
controlled for an analysis and even if
we did given the way the data was
collected we may not have the design set
up
that we can actually account for the
influences each of these different
sectors so definitely awesome
limitations when working with patient
data and using inter patient variability
as a surrogate for understanding
regulation of a specific pathway but
there are some advantages too so it's
good just to keep both of those in mind
in terms of addressing those limitations
and thinking about what other
experimental data or platforms out there
may be useful I think one area that's
really exciting right now is single cell
profiling so for instance single cell
RNA seek or some of the food I message
lieutenants these are all really great
platforms with a allow us to look at
what is the distribution gene expression
in terms of cell to cell across the
whole population and I think this is
really fascinating because it means that
we can look at a population of isogenic
cells so all the genetic background of
these cells is is all identical
therefore the changes that we're seeing
at the level of gene expression are due
to basically differences in the system
so we can really start to understand mr.
Kaster city that's occurring across
transcriptome and start to understand
the functional consequences so I think
integrating or augmenting the things
that we find in the context of patient
populations with what's actually going
on then at the single cell level would
be really really fascinating and
powerful integrating gene expression and
DNA methylation in the context of CUNA's
highlighted succinct kernel related
structures what other data types could
be integrated with gene expression head
originates to further understand
transcriptional regulation
so I think in this day and age there are
so many different kinds of datasets that
we can integrate and it's really it used
to be a bottleneck about technology that
we couldn't necessarily do these kinds
of couple experiments where we could
grab the RNA and then the DNA or the
methylation profiles of the same sample
but nowadays we a lot more of these
couple methods that are becoming
accessible and reliable and so I think
it's actually more of a bottleneck about
by cymatics models that need to step up
and be able to integrate this data I
think for energy expression variability
methylation for us was a very obvious
first step to integrating the changes
that we saw at the level of gene
expression with what was going on in
methylation but there are other data
types that would be I think equally
illuminating of how the system is being
regulated one of those is to look at
genetic variation so an obvious question
would be upstream in the promoter region
of these patients can we find a subset
of snips that may be relevant one one
subset of patients this is another that
would lead to increased or decreased
variability in the expression of that
that transcript
another type of data set that would be
really interesting to look at would also
be at the proteomic level so the changes
in gene expression variability lead to
more stable abundance of certain
proteins in which case there would be a
very interesting functional
interpretation and I think proteomics is
an interesting area because in terms of
protein stability and variability there
are certain distributions that are being
modeled nowadays and we know about that
so depending on half-life and different
distributions like the gamma or the
beador
there's a correlating that with what we
see in terms of stability and gene
expression across the population would
be would be quite interesting too I
would like to once again thank dr.
Jessica morrow for her presentation I
would also like to thank Bob for making
the committee's educational web task law
school before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August and from the 17th you'll
receive an email and lab letting you
know when the press will be available to
comply please share the announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again goodbye